tailor women are watching there is a a
sex toy called the womanizer this is the
worst name but it sucks on your clitoris
whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't put it in
you it just you put it over your [ __ ]
and it has like a little like hole and
yes that's it you put the RT ball huh
you put that little opening over your
[ __ ] that's it that's exactly what I
have but it's blue and then you press
the top button and it starts sucking and
then you press the bottom button to like
up the suction and it's if you've never
squirted before which I hadn't get one
of these and you will oh my not every
time but it's this thing is a game
changer and it's taught me that if I
ever eat Lizzie yes where you can at
least Gleek I bet out of a job oh dude
yeah exactly that is how far the key
can't water a plan or anything kids no
I'm the times that I've squirted like
I've scored it twice it was more of like
a spill yeah like it's just all of a
sudden you're like oh what the hell oh
wow the government's gonna have to clean
this up you know a lot of [ __ ] people
are gonna fight and fill out insurance
wouldn't call FEMA like how much like
enough to like damp in a small burger
like enough to ruin a slope that is
exactly the right amount no I would say
half a juice box for me
oh yeah which is enough to dampen a
burger for sure about it Nick these keep
popping it's not your fault but you're
not hearing it it might just be the
headphones yeah yeah I'm not hearing ok
good as long as it's not peaking in that
um yeah man I got some the squirting
thing is like it's a you know it's a I'm
trying to liken it to something it's
like it's just wild man it's a watt like
I like this one girl I knew like she
there was so much squirting sometimes
like I would like check to see if she
was okay like it was like I was like it
was almost biblical you know a couple of
chapters of it it was just like this is
you know I felt bad like the cat would
come around because he thought I'd cut
the foss at all I just kind of like dude
and you had
change all the [ __ ] like at a certain
point like sorry if you're a squirter
and you know that you are the guy could
put a towel down yeah I guess like
having period sex like plan you know
what's gonna happen I will say that
sometimes girls squirt and they're like
I didn't what is it like the first time
and then don't don't make them feel bad
about that but a girl should not ruin
your mattress yes like the last time I
squirted what's the second time I've
ever squirted which I'm in five years of
my life but from the first time in the
second time I didn't see it coming right
like I wasn't like I'm gonna squirt
right now and then all of a sudden I was
like I would have not picked a different
position on my bed I would have put down
a towel like right it's a nuisance
because then there's a wet spot but yeah
so that thing was laying out back to the
hookup situation so that things laying
out that little [ __ ] in the urgent as an
ulterior motive dude well this this
device has taught me that if I ever um
eat [ __ ] which I don't like I don't I
think I probably would really so in my
life yeah you're about probably six
months away from what I see right now I
am yeah okay so this is what I've
learned is that you don't like licking
is fine but like you gotta suck that
click that's what brothers do and a lot
of black dudes get down there and
they'll they're doing it right oh yeah
another dude latch on to that thing like
a barnacle I literally don't let go they
watch the nay oh I swear to god it is
that is that's the game-changing move I
would never have known it had I not
gotten this device and I have a vagina I
would have never known like suck on your
clip that seems weird but it's not wild
its I'm telling you the next time you go
down on a girl suck her [ __ ] and like
you will get orgasms out of her that she
didn't even know she you can just suck
directly on it full suck don't here's on
not the whole time but like just here's
the thing and this is gonna get kind of
gross but we're already there and it's
not even gross this is biology we keep
it yeah let's make it so it doesn't get
to grow no I know woman's clitoris is
our penises that aren't fully formed so
when you're in in utero or whatever
you're trying to form dude one girl I
remember that thumb wrestling down here
exactly I mean this thing was really
sometimes girls have Hugh
I was oh and two against this thing when
I was trying to touch this lady's been
chewed this clitoris definitely seemed
like if I can could have worn you know
part of a mitten this thing was gonna
rhyme they you know yeah because she
probably has more testosterone yeah yes
no she's title nine definitely you know
yeah that [ __ ] title not and per se
you know what I'm saying
yes so my the whole theory is I'm gonna
learn this so your dance so-so clips are
just dicks right little bitty dicks that
are in hiding yeah so treat her [ __ ]
like you would a tiny tiny penis if you
would if you had a tiny penis how you
would want a girl to suck your dick so
that is that is exact method Wow so that
should change everyone's style if you're
not already doing something like that
like you really need to focus on suction
as opposed to licking and whatever that
is and I'm a girl that requires a lot of
pressure down there like any time a guy
has ever like fingered me like outside
my like I'm always like you need to go
harder you need to go hard like I can't
I mean it's like deep within yeah and
I've had guys be like does that hurt and
I'm like I can't even feel it I can't
even feel it guy and then this this
device was recommended to me by a doctor
that I talked to on my show I had a show
about sex and I was telling her I it
takes so much pressure for me to have an
orgasm and she was like you need the
womanizer Wow
and and now and this was the toy so hmm
that was laying out was it made in China
do you know what countries playing maybe
Honduras a lot of these a lot of the
real good ones are made in I'm really
yeah
what and you kind of want that I think
it's lady you want something from
[ __ ] South America I know I do I want
to go down there and there's that
Chinese single just beat the hell out of
a jean you know what I got too oh yeah
but I want one that malfunctions and
like doesn't let me have a choice
because that's my problem with
masturbation theater is that I like to
be dominated and be like oh you think
like cuz whenever I am masturbate I
always get to a point that it's like it
feels great but then it almost starts to
feel like you're you know when someone
tickles you and you're like oh this is
fun and then you're like no no but
that's like if they keep tickling you it
like you might die your heart might stop
yeah but it's also very exciting I
always feel like when I'm
about to have an orgasm it's always
almost like that feeling of like no stop
stop those elbows up like it's too much
feeling and when I'm masturbating I can
just stop because I'm in control and I
need sometimes to persevere past that to
have an organ yeah so I feel like my
problem with masturbation is that I'll
give up too soon because I'm like it's a
little bit uncomfortable and I feel like
it's too much I don't want to come and
then I I have control and so then it's
not as fun and that's that's been my so
I would love a device to malfunction and
be like [ __ ] you don't have a choice
right we're latching on yeah you want a
device to [ __ ] show up and not pay
your mortgage and just [ __ ] you against
the wall yes you can't even see then
you're blind just wandering around no
mortgage it's all room with my wife
yeah but you are dealt but you have been
dealt with yes what's up guys sitting
here with this marijuana plant I think
also could be just a regular plant it
could be poison ivy brought about to
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clips and Charlie here you
know I'm saying